hi maya hi
thanks for coming on the show now frost
i'm super excited for this how to not be
a boring grown-up
yeah there is going to be other things
people too
we were we're gonna talk about your life
too i'm excited
you have a lot of stuff that you like
doing
which is awesome well
that's true so i love skateboarding
i know you have in your instagram you
have yeah
i'm drawing i love surf
i like surf karate skateboarding kung fu
and surfing and skateboarding
oh and boxing and wrestling
yeah that's a lot of awesome exposure to
all these diverse activities which one
do you like any of them the most
um well i like them all
yeah but some of them are just really
hard and
like really you have to be strict about
them like
you just really need to be strict about
it and like to learn
it you actually need to get into it and
like do
every step
was it your mom that helped you get
involved in a lot of them or how did you
pick that you want to do those
i just wanted it yeah
my dad got me into fighting but
skateboarding
surfing i got by i just saw and i liked
it
yeah the first day i came to america
i saw a skateboard and i'm like mom i
didn't know what it is but i like it
could you buy me one she's like okay on
the first day
then i just start trying it and then i'm
like mom i love it even though i
i haven't like i have no idea i have
zero idea what it is but
i just do i like it yeah
yeah yeah you have a lot of awesome
pictures and videos of yourself
skateboarding on your instagram
yeah of course you have so many of them
actually we showed a couple of them when
your mom was on the show too
for those that don't haven't watched
that episode that it's the one with
lyanna moon you can go watch that one on
the chat um
yeah but this is also
maya's instagram it's the link in the
bio if you want to go and check it out
followed
a lot of other really cool interviews
he's been doing it for three years just
like i've been doing three years
that's right well not surfing serving
two years yeah
did you come because lyanna when your
mom was on the show she told us that
she had you in in india
and then you got born in india
and that was 2002
is that right 2012 sorry 2012.
that's when you were born right yeah
2012.
or 2011 2012 2012. okay
and then when did you come to los
angeles
three years ago four years ago i was six
three almost three years ago
okay and you saw the skateboard
and i and i said mom i like it
and then she was like well it's just i'm
like mom what is it i like it i know
what it
is but i just like how it looks then she
was like
well i could tell you what
it is and buy you one and then i'm like
really
like i don't know what it is and you're
going to buy me one
then i tried it and
it was just such an intense feeling i
loved it
and i was like mom i don't understand
why do i love it so much i just do
and then when i saw the skate park i'm
like mom i see skateboards there so what
is for skateboards my mom like no
you don't have to go there right now
because like
but i got her to go there
and she was afraid for me to fall i was
falling
bleeding all the time but i was happy
about it yep because i learned how to do
it better
and my mom was proud of me but really
scared for me too
yeah yeah it's important to
let kids be kids and to not constrain
them
in the bubble of protection it's very
important
so you bled and you fell while you're
skateboarding but you become a
better skateboarder and now you're going
down
those what are the call what is it
called the bowls right
yeah the balls the bowls and show them
you're jumping off of um
those are actually pretty high those
jumps that you're doing as well
those are those are no joke so these are
the bowls
that we're talking about
this is two years ago this is a year
after i learned
getting ooh let's see when the internet
kick shows through there it is
it's a little on slower side let me get
the whole thing to play it yeah
it is fine so should be able to get the
whole thing here
just a little on the slower side right
now there we go let's see if we can get
speed up right now
yeah it's fine this is at the venice
skate park right yeah is that the venice
skate park
love it and that's only one of like
you have so many of these awesome videos
i did it backwards there too so
get it um yep i did it backwards
sometimes like you could go frontwards
and backwards and i went backwards up
that time
oh yeah you mean like no
i flip over with my board and then i
turn backwards
yeah yeah that's what i did on that
video
do you remember when when you were
growing up
i'm wondering if you remember because
you were telling me a little bit that
you remember like
playing with elephants and stuff like
that when you're growing up in india
i was a little baby and
um i i saw
me and my mom saw an elephant and
the the two most the three most intense
memories i have is me remembering that
baby elephant
my dad is showing his music
to me for the first time but i was one
years old
with the headphone down like this
smiling
and another one
is when my mom helped me climb on top of
a
tree dad playing music
elephant mom helping climb a tree
that's awesome and then so then you when
you're
coming here you're picking up all these
new activities this is probably one of
the things about how to not be a boring
adult plus my mom told me that when she
was pregnant
she wrote a motorcycle that's why he
might
love these like really dense experience
too that's right
and plus i remember when i was like when
i was a
one-year-old two-year-old three-year-old
four-year-old
then in india she drove me on the back
she she had a big motorcycle a big black
motorcycle
and then she would have like a big seat
so there would be enough space for
a little child so i'd go on the back
she'd go in the front
and she would make me hold her and then
she would put her hands like this
and then she would drive like this and
then like kind of holding my hand not
too strong though
and i was holding on to her like this
yep
so this is probably one of the main
themes of how to not be a boring adult
is to do a lot of different things like
what you're interested in because like a
lot of adults
they just stay there work not play not
doing
nothing that a kid would ever do
yeah i'm a child myself and i'd never be
a boring girl enough because
i know how to be fun and it's
a thing which everybody should have
it's a thing that every single person
should have
old people like
kind of like old like 30 years old
should not be born should be really fun
children everyone should be it that
everybody in this world should be fun
not be boring stay there do work and
then just do nothing
like you know happiness get really fun
yes that's great activities yes yes
more fun you remember what happened
today is that we were exploring
we're playing yeah we're playing with
the disc we're playing with the punching
bag outside we're playing frisbee all
this different stuff and then
yeah maya decides we're gonna we're
gonna go upstairs and we go upstairs and
there's this area where you can kind of
like
go outside and then i said let's climb
the roof i love
climbing i climbed on the very top
it was high extreme and
fun yeah it was and you know as an adult
for the last almost like
three almost four weeks now of being
here
that i hadn't climbed the roof yet as an
adult
it didn't even you know occur that i
should go and explore on the roof and so
this is probably a pretty good example
of how to
not be boring how to be fun how to
explore how to keep doing that kind of
stuff
while you're an adult it's really
important
it's novel it's fun it's playful we
we hung out up on the roof for like
15-20 minutes just hanging out talking
it's a lot of fun pulling each other's
hair
it was a lot of silly things you know
and like adults don't
adults they wouldn't do that they'd be
like what the heck like
yeah yeah so like it hurts uh no
don't do that no that that this
and today i didn't want to ruin the
surprise but
we are going to be drawing
having fun and boom we're going to be
playing
and wherever we're going we
are going to be fun and today i'm
teaching
alan how to be
the most fun grown-up
it's right i agree with this the more
that you
influence my soul the more that i become
more playful
that's right i agree more fun i
even have a documentary about me and my
mom
and like in a lot of parts i say that
i fall i cry really bad it hurts
and then my mom always comes to help me
and say
my you got it and hugs me and then i go
back and then
i don't feel the pain yeah
my mom would always say that i got it
that
never give up never give up and that's
the words that
actually made me not give up because i
would give up then
yeah yeah this is a really important
influence from parents is that when you
say never give up
that it motivates the kid to continue
pursuit it also
is important that mom and dad expose you
to so many different things if you're
talking about
not only skateboarding but also surfing
and boxing and
karate and music and art drawing
yeah i do and plus i do music
i do singing i do piano i do drumming
and i also do it
and i do like all the sports i do work
out yeah and i love drawing too
art and drawing arts and crafts for my
dolls
and so the exposure's another thing
because usually adults what happens is
that they end up only doing
one thing that becomes the only thing
that they do and that's why you know one
of the things that
that we do a lot on the show is we at
least try and and draw the really good
concepts that people are talking about
or in this case we'll see what happens
but
you know some of the interesting
insights that you know your mom also
talked about on the show was that that
you have a lot of
thoughts around what you think god is
which is very interesting and soul and
all these types of things and that's
important for young people for young
people and adults because
a lot of adults don't have a perspective
on what they think
god is and that to have it when you're
younger is really
important and it's
it makes a smarter young person
i don't just like drawing
i like drawing certain things
what do you like drawing should you want
to show us some stuff
sorry to interrupt but
i made this oh yeah the hat let's do it
i made this really cool hat
so does that say sausalito on it uh-huh
it does say salsalito on it
yup that's a city in the north bay so
i wrote a lot of fun stuff on it like
happy
happy happy happy and i wrote
do not be sad be like a rainbow
feel like you're sliding over a rainbow
i know you know how to
be happy and it says unmatchable stuff
and then it says
happy happy happy and then it has a
little elephant
a little koala yeah and then like
there's a little elephant sliding over a
rainbow
and it says there boom boom
baby boom boom baby
so did you you wrote all of that and you
made the patch you added the patches to
it yeah
what does the long one say again
[Music]
do not i could show you there
it has it has like rainbows over it too
next to it yeah it does what does it say
what did you write
do not be sad be like a rainbow
feel like you're sliding over a rainbow
i know you know how to be happy
i love that
that's so good and on my birthday
in six days i'm going to have a slumber
party going to the salon with my friends
and plus the fun part is we're going to
be
making hats like this together
yeah and i love how you write happy on
it a bunch
boom boom baby the rainbows don't be sad
slide over a rainbow life is kind of
like sliding over a rainbow
are those some of your favorite animals
that you also chose look good in it
what yeah um so an elephant is one of my
favorites
uh wolf is one of my favorites and a
horse
like i said unmatchable stuff
and you just rode a horse yesterday you
said yeah
that's good that you're so frequently
getting exposure to
animals like that that's good and you
like dogs and cats
yeah i just love animals love animals
and you became vegan that was something
your mom mentioned too
yeah so i became vegan by myself because
i feed
feel bad for the animals and
like milk is for a cow for baby cow
and eggs are actually
something that was actually alive inside
there
and yeah like that belongs to them
and eating them is actually not what
we're supposed to do
because humans are originally supposed
to eat plants
and these are alive animals and at one
time
so a friend loves beef and meat and
stuff and he loves killing bugs
and i have a friend emerson she's a
vegan too but she would
eat eggs and
she she doesn't like killing bugs either
or
eating animals she's really nice animals
just like me
but like one time he was killing
bugs and stuff and eating beef and then
we were like
imagine that would be you imagine like
yeah
somebody just like a giant stepped on
your mom and then she died and you were
crying for help and then
they stepped on you and you died too yes
and then you're like whatever at least
it's not me and then when we
said it more and more to him he started
thinking about it like what if it
actually was me
yeah i've been to a slaughterhouse
that's not a fun experience it's an
enlightening one
but it's uh it's a slaughterhouse that's
where they kill the animals
yeah yeah well
actually i work um
as for saving animals
like the ones they kill for for hoodies
and stuff
the ones that they eat and my dad's
friend
actually works for it and he is and he
just
gave me a job to do it too yeah you can
make
leather out of mushrooms and you can
there's a lot of good ways to grow
meat that doesn't use animals as well
so you guys are gonna make hats on your
birthday in six days
yep is that so this is a this
interesting idea so
is it gonna be all white hats and
they're gonna write on them and like
black sharpie and stuff or
what is it going to be so
it's actually going to be like a
like kind of like skin color tone
but mine is going to be white
and you're going to write new messages
on them yeah
they could do whatever they want with
them but i'm writing messages
on them it's like every time that you
take your hat off you think about like
your messages that you wrote on them
right
like happy happy happy that's great yeah
yeah when i'm sad actually i look at the
side i'm like no
why the heck do i have to be sad let's
be happy again
why am i even sad four
yeah such a little thing let's just
no i'm not sad yeah
you also were telling me that you like
electric cars a lot which is interesting
i hate
not electric cars
yeah i just hate um
like stuff that killed the earth
it's just evil like
yeah it's our house people created
so much things that kill the earth
and plus um
so i said like my mom asked me
if you'd be god how do you create people
but what the question started with is i
said
mom so everything creates something
and who created god and she was like if
you would be god who would create
people then i said well
i'd make the soul build itself i
wouldn't create it i'd
give the soul the ability to create its
own
human like a human creates a house and
then lives in it
yeah so then it would be like
everything is god but that the souls get
to build themselves
yeah like this like like like little
pieces flying from god
but they turn into souls and then the
god gives them
ability to build themselves like they
build their
own human around them and then they live
in the human so the human
dies breaks like like a human
builds a home and lives in it till it
has
problems until it breaks
it's a it's a really good perspective on
reality
yeah i like that one
how did you come up with that you know i
don't know it came out my brain
brains but does it have something to do
with the fact that like
your mom is also focused on meditation
and intuition but she was shocked she
was impressed like
i wouldn't ever think of that my friends
wouldn't either nobody would think of
that
a lot of adults don't think of that a
lot of adults
get close-minded and they don't think of
interesting things like
and you know what i said
so kids shouldn't be
punished kids should never get punished
and kids should like never
like get rules because that's how
grown-ups are like
actually dumber than kids because like
their parents would give
them like things like rules like rule
number one you don't do this you don't
do that you don't
do this and that and that oh if you do
you get a punishment
so they shouldn't be grown up with
scaredness yeah if they wouldn't be
growing up with scaredness they
would actually be so much smarter
yeah because they would because their
parents would let them
create and be their own selves yes yes
but like so i had this horrible
kindergarten where one time i was
playing with a
toy car like you know these little hot
wheel things
i was playing with it and then
all of a sudden the teacher said all the
toys you could play with
there's a shelf with you with the toys
you can't play with with the toys you
can't play with
and i took the toys from the shelf you
can play with
and then the teacher put me on the wall
for the
whole day and it was actually till night
time
the kindergarten so i had to stay there
which is mean the teachers is mean and
one time
i drew a blue dog i was only four years
old and i
and she said ew it's so ugly blue dogs
don't even exist what the heck
that's what she said she's like it's
ugly there's no such thing as a blue
dog and then you know what my mom said
well you should tell her that actually
they do exist because
in america she actually did see a blue
dog
take that teacher and she wouldn't let
me like create a blue
dog i'm a child yeah yeah i i like
unicorns i like blue
dogs yeah with wings on them that could
fly and she said
ew it's ugly because it's not real
and you drew it bad anyways because you
didn't do it by the wall
yeah this is not fun is the idea of some
sort of
rules or fear programming is something
that we kind of talk about is that the
generations pass along to us some sort
of a set of like you can't imagine a
blue dog you can't draw that
you can't imagine the unicorn that flies
and that
you can't play with these toys
and then it sets in over time and that's
why an adult
becomes close-minded because they've had
all these rules
passed down and then they just became
dumb so like all these schools actually
make you
dumb not smart cause like they give you
rules all the time like two plus two
can't be six nope it just can't
no it can't because it's a rule
and they say like you dummy it's a rule
two plus two can't be six and imagine
they wouldn't say that and just let the
kid
and say it's right if two plus two would
be ten
two plus two would be six and all the
kids would just do different answers
they would say it's right they say
everything is right it's fine it's fine
when they grow up they'd have such a
good imagination
won't be like so like oh that rule oh
yeah that
rule like you know grown-ups like they
always think like
like if you like want to like do
something you're like
you like grown-ups always think like oh
yeah i should go
oh no i forgot the whoa what
taught me when i was little
they shouldn't be thinking that when
kids should like be
open-minded like can i ask a question
though
yeah would it be a good idea to maybe
have a rule
let's say like the on the ten
commandments or the noble eightfold path
there are these really nice
spiritual traditions of the planet where
they have these ideas of rules and one
of them is things like you shouldn't
kill another
person is that a fair rule that's a fair
rule but i'm talking about
rules yeah that hold the imagination yes
yes
so some rules are okay like don't kill
other people
but other people like don't like drive
on a car
this way so you don't crash into each
other yes yes
okay here and you're here this is
interesting so you can
have even some rules in terms of you
know driving on the right side of the
road in the united states is important
instead of the left so that's a rule
you stop at the stop sign generally is
important if it's in the middle of
the night and there's no cars you can
probably do a rolling stop
when there's no cars there's no humans
there's no bikes so things like this so
you can kind of maybe play with rules a
little bit
too a little bit yeah i mean like
kindergarten like
parent rules like this should let you be
open-minded like
i do blue doggy i'm like teachers this
pretty look has only
four and she's like oh no
of course it's not it's ugly there's
no such thing as a blue dog
imagine if people like walt disney or
like the team at pixar
and these really imaginative people were
told when they were
making things that are really insightful
that no you can't make that because it
doesn't exist
and that's not that's a bad way to hold
people's imagination back
we we need to let imagination something
i asked you actually on the roof
and then i don't even like i'm a teacher
this is ugly i know
and then she was like no that is
actually
really pretty i don't like teacher no
it's a poop color and i like that blue
dog more
then she's like no that blue dog is so
extremely ugly never draw that ever
again i
hate it do you remember when i asked you
on the roof
what you would do if you were
a designer of the universe remember i
asked you that
because if you were right you could make
whatever you want blue dogs you could
make different
kind of human as you were saying the
vehicle for the soul to make the body
so there's different ways of expressing
imagination and creativity so
if you want to do it as a blue dog
nobody should hold you back from
using your imagination and such yeah fun
ways
but and like i love drawing fears
unicorns mermaid like
loved it so much and one time i took a
notebook
in class i not class kinder
when it was break time for 10 minutes i
i drew like a little mermaid or
something i showed it to the teacher she
was like no it's ugly
every drawing which is magical she would
say ew
it is extremely ugly
why would you even draw that i was so
sad i i was just crying every day
because of that teacher just saying
oh my god it's just so
ugly like you just drew a rainbow
it's just so ugly
draw something more realistic like why
did you even draw
somebody sliding over a rainbow it's
just so
ugly oh no that like blows my mind i was
like
okay i'll draw a brown dog i'll draw
just a regular rainbow i
i won't draw anything magical and then
since then i just
didn't draw anything magical and then
like and then i saw street art
i think that's the key is that you have
to draw things that are magical i like
that that's a good key
and then when i went to
um when i went to
america i saw street art yeah like
that's not real and people get millions
of dollars for it
people love it and my teacher is saying
you it's so ugly because it's
not the color it's supposed to be and
it's not even real
yeah so you would say that one of the
main things about
being a open-minded grown-up so being
not
boring being a fun grown-up is to make
sure you can keep your imagination
strong that's probably top thing because
actually
imagination and thinking about things
which are not real
can actually help you in real life yeah
more than believing that oh yeah there's
no just
thing as a blue dog ill
yeah that actually keep you scared of
everything like that's not real
oh no oh no no we can do that we can't
do that because that's a rule
but that that rule could actually make
you die or like the opposite of the rule
could actually
save your life and imagination can save
your life because
if you have a really strong imagination
like if there's a fire you can just
create an idea right away and then just
salute here i'm here i'm fine yeah
and like nothing even happened but like
a person that doesn't have imagination
at all
would just stay there and die because
they don't have an
imagination they can't think of anything
yeah
remember when we were on the roof and a
plane flew over and i told you that a
hundred years ago we didn't have those
remember that well it required
a hundred and approximately 20 years ago
the wright brothers
also there were no planes back then
so you couldn't do something like fly
from moscow to los
angeles in one day it would take you
three weeks
to go by boat across the
atlantic ocean and then go through the
canal and or go around the pacific side
and so it really required imagination
to see something that didn't exist
usually what entrepreneurship or in
business what people do
is they see that something doesn't exist
and then they have to so they imagine
the world
having that new thing and then they
create that new thing
so if we don't use that muscle we become
non-creative
like you're also describing with the
fire in order to get out of the fire you
have to be creative
yeah um and like imagine a person
without like without an imagination
which was raised with
rules brown dogs can't draw blue ones
that's the rule bam that's the rule you
can't
no no creative things no that's the rule
they're they're bad
so imagine a person like that growing up
in them thinking
the canoes are probably too slow what
should i do about it
then they all thinking about it for
years
they can't like i'm still thinking about
the canoe thing
and he can't think of anything and a
person who has an imagination
was raised that you can draw a blue dog
that will exist if you want it to
boom blue dogs exist now actually
because
people created dog paint
paint to paint dogs
boom and like a person with an
imagination
grows up then they're like oh the canoes
are
too slow what should i do
bam it's going to be car called an air
row plane like an aero plane
and now i just created how to make it
yeah i made it and i'm going to fly
fast and easy that's what
a person with an imagination
that's how they always solve problems
yeah
yeah this is spot on i completely agree
with this if you're grown up so if
you're a child
as you're being raised into the world
the more that
you have mom and dad and
teachers and community that
family that helps you foster an
imagination so it helps your
imagination blossom and flourish like a
flower
versus if you're in the
normal school system and that if the
teacher like you're saying in
kindergarten
this is not a good teacher one that kind
of
destroys the imagination that's going
gonna lead to problems
and like other kids like
and and she loved this little little
girl
one little girl which was six she was
that girl was so simple
like just so simple just playing with
she was playing with the toy car like
this
like this sitting like this on the
ground
and then yeah and then having a little
ponytail
just like simple simple boring yeah
no no imagination and she loved that
girl she would always hug her like such
a good girl oh my gosh i
love you so much then look at me she
would be screaming
there is no such thing as a blue dog
what the heck what do you mean
and she would get me in such big trouble
for like drawing a blue dog
a child is supposed to draw rainbows
unicorns yeah yeah blue dogs
yeah and then like i had other kids at
class
and she loved another boy and he was
really simple too
just black and white that's it
imagination black and white
clothes black and white everything just
yeah
like an old picture and
yeah there was another kid which was
actually
this is literally taking the genius out
of kids
which is really unfortunate because we
need the creativity in the world
really badly to solve the big problems
to build the future
and i'm just imagining how many young
people
end up having their like imagine if maya
was unable to pursue her imagination
as an adult and there was this girl that
actually became
mean because um of that teacher telling
her no
no that's horrible she became mean and
she started being mean to everyone
and that girl one girl loved cats she
loved them
she like she would think about pink cats
and that you liked hers
and then the two you're like no no such
thing
as pink cats dirt they'd be so
ugly take your imagination away
and then that other one love the
unicorns and pink bunnies
then you like there's no such thing as
pink bunnies
they're ugly and your imagination is
ugly too that's what you would tell to
everybody who's creative
then that girl actually became mean oh
wow and really really really angry
at life oh wow
yeah so people become resentful they
become angry and mean when their
imagination is taken away from them yeah
cuz like
then she was just like without an
imagination pink bunny shoes and then
that's it that's the only thing from her
memory
she had
wow so even as simple as a blue dog or a
pink bunny or rainbows
that these sort of simple imaginative
drawings for kids to be able to express
themselves
is really important to not destroy that
imagination
as a teacher as a parent but that
teacher would
scream at them so loudly just like
literally
yelling like yelling yeah no not yet
like actually screaming
and like screaming screaming at us
should he get so mad it's screaming at
us
we're drawing a pink bunny or a blue
doggy wow
and is this in the public is this a
public school system
is public school yeah it was in russia
oh it was russia okay yeah and
so that seems to make a little bit more
sense i don't know why
in the i don't know maybe teachers are
really nicer
you think so yeah duh and they're nicer
than the us
they're nicer than the us they're as
nice
yeah but that one was just evil not
letting you yeah yeah yeah there's just
evil
people sometimes she said you guys have
to draw this cat
you guys have to like draw and color it
this way and one time i like drew it
a blue shirt a blue
shirt then she starts screaming at me my
it's
ugly why would you draw that you didn't
do it by the steps
that's what she would scream at anybody
who like added
like a little bow or a little
pink in their eyes she would scream that
they were like you're not
drawing a real cat it doesn't look like
a real cat what are you doing
yeah and i drew a blue shirt and boots
and she's like there's no such thing as
a cat with bits or a shirt and take my
imagine
yeah then i start thinking yeah that's
true it doesn't exist and then i didn't
really like it no more
yeah yeah if
for me it seems like there's a lot of
genius and creativity that is being
destroyed in adults
because they have so much potential to
retain that
childhood aw i remember maya was on the
computer
i have these i have these two monitors
on the computer and maya first grabbed
the mouse
and then was moving the mouse between
the two monitors and she was watching
the mouse
jump from monitor to monitor and she
just had this amount of
awe in just that process she was like
whoa
watching the mouse as she moved it and
like we kind of get conditioned
in many ways to lose our
ah our happiness our
emotions of of novelty
about life every breath can feel that
way
every we were watching a hummingbird
while we were on
the roof and that was hummingbird i love
hummingbirds i love
i just love my life like
life is happy like even looking at this
fire
is interesting but somebody without an
imagination
yeah opposite of me would look at this
fire like
oh just a boring gold fire whatevs
now uh just an old boring mask
who cares it's a little curved and it
moves to side to side it's
it's just normal yeah
yeah in science we also call it hedonic
adaptation and so it's basically that
like what
after you walk up to the water fountain
and you press the button and it gives
you water
you get so used to that process you
become adapted to it
that it's no longer interesting it's no
longer
beautiful anymore but it is you can just
press a button and get water
fresh clean water well
guess what so i
so you know what i said about rich
people
rich people and spoiled kids
could get anything they want
so they're not interested in anything
because they already got it
all and they're like there's nothing
else different
how boring
like a little diamond i already have
like
10 of those a toy a chair
and everything is just so boring because
nothing's different for them
like nothing's new for them because they
already have
everything
yeah it's interesting theory about
wealth yeah
but don't you see like
poor people by seeing
something new they'd be so happy to be
like what is that so much questions in
their
head and if they would see like a piece
of new clothing a piece of new that's a
piece of
nap they would just be so happy and like
people who already have it all
they're just like not grateful for it
yeah because
it's getting boring to them they're like
it's just so boring for me like
i don't need no anything
yeah i like i like that theory it's a
good one
what are you doing i was just about to
say the same thing let's do it
what colors do you want to draw with
i'll bring the
okay i'm very interested in what you're
gonna draw
there's black and then just black for
now
okay yeah okay okay all right
it's gonna it's i was gonna say it's
gonna be a blue dog
a blue dog he's just
or a pink bunny i just love it so much
just
yeah oh man
this has been a very insightful first
part of the conversation
just destroying the
creativity and imagination and genius
out of
children and then that is what leads to
adults that are zombies
wow it's way more insightful than
than we realize it is
it actually makes me really want to
change our
fabric of existence to where you know
pablo picasso talked about it a lot
you know he said you have to retain the
child yeah yeah and
plus picasso he he would draw such
interesting pictures because he had an
imagination
he would just draw like something
a flower if he wouldn't have the
imagination but he could
com made a combo of a lot of stuff yes
like
put like a boy
like a boy face next to slash girl face
plus half this half that have that and
one part is going to be like
rectangle one part is going to be a
triangle yeah yeah
exactly a combination of a bunch of
stuff that's not normal is creativity
i love it
that's why we're so synthesis driven
on the show we pull from a lot of
different places
and then we come up with ideas that are
not
normal and then that's creativity
that's imagination
like you know this is cool
yeah like you know like
kids get a time of bedtime but if they
wouldn't have rules of bedtime
then one time like if they would like
sleep that time what if a fire would
start
they would be sleeping they're like no
that's the rule i need to sleep
now and then the fire starts it
right when they fall asleep but if you
like stay up
do drawings you would you'd see so
much things even maybe save lives
because you know one time a fire started
at night
and so much people died of not noticing
it
and going to sleep yeah
this is a good exercise for people to do
at home right now
as well is like get out your drawing pad
get out some blank paper
get out some markers and draw something
and make it something that doesn't exist
make it something with your imagination
your creativity
and then basically do that process over
and over and over and over again
and eventually i think what's going to
happen is you're gonna come up with
something that's really
actually truly interesting and novel
that's
that can bring value to the world okay
let's share
okay so here's the over-the-shoulder
shot
i can show them
all right what are we looking at it is a
fox
which is half demon half god wait a fox
that's half demon half god
oh let me die oh my gosh okay okay
i forgot this part
oh yeah interesting yeah i see what you
added
it's a pretty good that's a pretty good
fox and this half
demon no but i could draw a better one
i'm just running like kind of mad
and it's is this a tornado yeah pulling
down to hell and then this one's pulling
it up um
heaven yeah heaven let me see if i can
change the mixed effect quick and then
that'll give us a
boom all right so now i should be able
to just switch this up to
that doesn't exist does it boom
no this does not exist i like this a lot
this is great
and then the wings pulling it up and
then what's the well actually
you know a lot of things you do you know
what my dad said that
everything you think of is actually real
yeah
instead of boogie biggie gaga which i
said
that probably exists somewhere
yeah in baby language
and guess what i thought of a monster
and then he told me a whole story about
that monster that i explained about
there you go that's a creative song
[Music]
and then like everything i told him he's
actually that's real that's really he
told me stories all about it
i'm gonna i'm gonna draw something also
do you want me to take the marker yeah
okay i wonder if
you can share with us while i draw
something
so guys what's up what's up guys
why don't you tell us about your yin
yang panda dress
you just have to keep doing it in the
mic though
okay
so you have to yeah just keep doing the
mic i
have a yin yang dress
yeah yeah i'll change it to this one
yeah there you go so see it's a panda
slash yang yang get it cause the panda
is black and white
and it's from estate which actually
is the one who is like really famous
with yin yang that's probably pandas are
really famous there too
so i got yang yang right here
let me show you close up
so here's my yin yang
and it's a it's
a bear panda slashing yang
yeah black and white is my favorite
color so i love yin yang
it's interesting that black and white is
your favorite color
i know and the pink
oh you hate pink yeah that's pretty good
timing you got the pink out
i have uh something that i think you'll
find
you'll find uh enjoyable here is that
your favorite dress
so one of them wait bring the mic closer
again there you go
well maybe we were not
sorry about that guys
maybe not was that your favorite hat uh
well maybe yeah
you know what
guys look i just picked it up with my
legs
what i have for you here
is i have
all right ready so yeah
this is what this is what i drew
i drew a
visual of what i think is kind of like
what you're talking about
regarding god i think
that it's interesting to think about
some sort of a
god or unity that's infinite and that
there are these
these interconnected extensions
of that that are the little souls can i
draw something else after
of course yeah of course you can and i
think
what else is interesting about this is
that it's not just humans right it's not
just the one vehicle you can have all
these different
ideas of what sentience can look like in
these different soul vehicles
um first of all why do you keep saying
vehicles
that's a car you know that right well
why can't this body be a vehicle for the
soul
um well what do you mean they don't
drive it don't aren't you the driver of
your body right now
well actually i am
so that's interesting right the vehicle
hitting my body not my soul my soul is
the one who keeps me
safe and alive
all right let's have you draw also i'm
going to move you into the shot again
yeah there you go
that's good that's good perfect that's
let's go let's go you can stop there you
can stop there
you stop there because i need i need you
to be in the shot
okay let's all right what's what what
color do you want
what color maya i
dun dun dun dun dun
man it's really your favorite color she
picked it twice
black and white yeah i don't see any
whites though
and plus one more than white you would
need white paper you would need
doc you need black paper to use a white
marker yeah
i don't think they give you white
markers because they i think they think
that all paper is going to be
no we're not all papers
well they think a vast vast majority of
them yeah yeah
hey remember how you were saying that
armenian people have hair everywhere
and it sometimes gets in your look at
that it's just a random hair on the
marker
of course there is i'm from armenia i
have hair on my legs
yeah and as everybody knows i obviously
have
hair everywhere as well yeah
[Music]
hey don't hate don't hate on i'm not
hating
i'm just laughing because i haven't too
yeah that's right
only on my legs what i'm a girl
oh wow this is good i'm looking forward
to this drawing
also it's pretty interesting for those
that don't know
maya was also recently
featured in what is this kids
abercrombie kids
it's pretty interesting
i think we shared this also on the show
with
lyanna
this is also some more of her art
this one's on the back of a shirt
no seriously though everybody needs to
practice art and creativity and
imagination
especially adults that are just
ruminating in their
default mode network
and that's why a lot of people take
substances and modernity is because
well they want to of course have a union
with the divine
and they'd attain it in a non natural
way as in you can get that without a
substance on a moment's moment basis
but then a lot of people are using
like micro doses on substances in order
to enable them to be
creative to get out of their excessive
perpetual constraints of thinking
but we need to enable that from young
age from the age of the child
and to you know truly
let that flourish and not restrain it or
constrain it
i mean if you know of a teacher
somewhere that's
focusing on just
constraining the minds of kids
get them out of the teaching position or
get them to augment their
ability to let kids be imaginative and
creative
we're all universe designers
that's another thing we are the
publishers and players of this reality
it's interesting metaphysical hypothesis
and that we ourselves designed this
reality and we design
other realities we are
that we are god we are doing this we're
consciousness exploring infinity
and that the more that you realize that
you yourself are a universe designer
that then the more that you realize that
you should not constrain your
imagination
you should unleash it and you should try
and
build things of value into the world
and this is why people like video games
virtual reality
people like that stuff because they like
being universe designers
they like being creators it's like a
video game where you can create a bunch
of stuff like minecraft
and roblox roblox is really easy totally
yeah yeah
do you know it yeah i do roblox yeah
yeah actually the one of the developers
of that uh
company one of the i think one of the
co-founding developers of that company i
tried getting on the show while i was in
san francisco
if you guys know any video game
designers
especially ones that are in the founding
teams of the companies that are
crushing it right now i would love to
interview them
on the show because it those are
literally the games that
expand kids imaginations that it makes
them into universe designers
and if you don't know it looks like this
for those that don't know
so this is the game
roblox and so
it looks kind of like let's see we'll
let's put it on videos let's see what we
get here
this isn't a it's an about us video
hi this is david of course yeah
here you go interesting so second color
of choice
has been red yeah at the same time that
a little red
block is coming on the screen here yeah
it's good timing again see that's the
universe those are synchronicities i
love those
oh yeah so
this is one of the
the many like universe designer games
that exists out there roblox
this is actually not a game right now oh
it's a trailer video yeah yeah
you should get roblox it cost a cent
yeah it's a and then it cost a dollar
basically yeah
and then there's these other ones
there's this one which is minecraft
i don't know what's wrong with um with
people that
don't see i think it's literally just
that whole thing about
being constraining kids i think is the
big thing
because i know so many people that don't
like these games
and i i think it has a lot to do with
not wanting to
allow universe design to happen
this is the official minecraft trailer
from almost 10 years ago
so again it's just literally building
universes building whatever you want to
build
it's all about it building yeah that's
what minecraft is
nothing else just building yeah
there's zombies in minecraft you can
kill them
see honestly
there's probably nothing that's better
than
the universe design games they're really
top-notch i think
um video games are something anyway
brown
okay blue and green here's brown
what do you need blue and green after
yeah okay
the reason why is because it actually
doesn't work the brown doesn't work
yep see oh really what
what what
oh whoa this is like dried out or
something you want to give me the lid
to it interesting let me give you a
different brown
is this one this should be good yeah
yeah this one okay cool um
yeah so blue and green blue and green
okay
thank you
yeah universe design games especially
are going to expand your consciousness
awareness imagination creativity and
that's why they're probably the best
games out there
so if you haven't yet just download
minecraft roblox
there's a bunch of these games that are
like this um like
slither i o is cool too how do you spell
that one
splitter io slither io oh i think i saw
that one up here actually
so it's like worms and you need i just
yep and if you're bigger than another
worm
you can eat the worm and there's like
little dots you can even get bigger and
bigger and you have to win to get the
biggest
oh interesting slither io see i haven't
i haven't even heard of this
is this kind of like the game snake
where you eat the dots
yeah except it looks like it's in a much
better
higher oh interesting
wow this is literally like snake oh yeah
you're done okay do you want another
color
no i'm finished okay
let's uh let's have you
let's have you expand for us what uh
what we're looking at now
okay i'll show it to them
you want to show it okay can you show it
to let's have you show it to this
show it to show it to that camera so
like this like put it like yeah yeah
yeah or that way you can talk about it
yeah
pull it yeah this
is jesus or here i'll hold it so you can
talk into the mic
is that okay okay so that way yeah like
this i'll put it right here
so so this is jesus
and like everyone thought he died
crying crying down on the ground but
he's actually there
standing up as god and giving them love
oh i see
okay so we have this is jesus giving
everybody love
right is all right yeah
um
jesus the body of jesus would you die
and then everybody's like crying to him
like oh my god
why did they kill him and then he's
actually standing up
happy giving them love as god yeah
this is a very another very interesting
drawing for um
i think everybody heard me right yeah
right right right yeah i think when you
were explaining it at first yeah
yeah i think yeah so if you need to hear
it again
it's jesus which is
so there's people crying for jesus
because he
he's dead but actually he's standing up
straight as god and giving them
love and giving happiness and happy
himself
i'm really happy that you drew this
yeah i feel like there's way too little
drawing of important concepts around
love compassion
sharing caring
that's what this is to me
and especially around spirituality so
okay i have another maybe you let's see
i have dots on me dots
yeah from like drawing or something
like freckles or something or what
what like that oh
like those yeah but those are probably
just
maybe it's because i'm 28. you know why
you know why
why um because like if you look at a
light too long then you see it
oh you were looking at the light oh i
see i see
can i ask you another question okay
we'll probably wrap we'll probably wrap
with uh
with this
all right what are some of your
favorite examples of
kids being wise because your mom gave a
bunch of examples
when she was on the show of times that
you were wise and i'm wondering
times if you remember of you being wise
or
other kids that are like you that were
wise well i remember me being wise that
me and my friend that when remember i
told you
our friend was killing bugs and actually
their enemies my friend and him
so and he was killing
bugs and eating beef and we told him
that
imagine that would be you like how do
you feel
and we said a really wise thing because
really like imagine just
stepping on bugs killing them for a
purpose eating
meat not caring and then imagining it
was
you how bad would you feel after that
yeah
i like i like that example you brought
it back yeah
that's a good one it's it's an exercise
in getting behind the perspective of
other in this case sentient life like
animals or
yeah yeah yeah that's good and i said
like you can't be mean to other things
because it's not you yeah yeah
yeah and the more enlightened people get
the more they realize it is them and
that that's why they shouldn't
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly and that is
them
in the future because karma there you go
his next life he could be that bug
and just get stepped on
there you go now
how did he feel he would be caring about
himself so much
yeah self-loving but not about anybody
else now he'll see how it feels for them
then he would start feeling
bad because they actually felt like he's
feeling in his second life
do you think that we're infinite
and eternal no if you do a lot of good
things you go to heaven if you do a lot
of bad things you go to hell if you do
both then you
get a new life
so free will acts as a
process of making decisions and over
time i'll make decisions and
over time you make a bunch of bad
decisions you go down down down down
down to hell and if you make really good
decisions you go
up up up up up to heaven but if you just
make both decisions like make one battle
one good
you go booth to another life to like
maybe see if you're going to hell or
heaven again
and again and again and again if you're
gonna do bad choices and good choices
but you're not going to remember that
you had another life
because you don't remember your last
life do you hmm
this is the in many ways this is the
buddhist
tradition the cycle of rebirth until you
liberate yourself from suffering from
greed
from aversion from craving when are we
again
wrapping up one last question okay okay
what is your favorite food
russian dumplings
even though i'm vegan russian dumplings
because i tried them before
so russian dumplings
russian dumplings russian dumplings
russian dumplings i could draw them for
you too
russian dumplings what do you like them
filled with
well the only thing they are filled with
is the meat no other options
hey they're actually there's some that
are filled with cabbage too like
piroshky and galoopsy filled with
cabbage you can get those
yeah but my fair ones are with me i know
i know i know it's usually beef yeah
good choice good choice yeah
maya thanks for coming on the show no
problem
this will teach us how to not be a
boring grown-up
yeah be fun
people be fun forever never
ever when you die the first thing you
say
is laugh
yeah retain that childhood
aw and creativity if
you are not in your childhood
ever again well i just thought you had
to go back into it so
be back into and do everything i told
you to do
never listen to people who say a blue
dog isn't real it looks ugly it's not
real it's not real it's not real
be as creative as you can and do
not listen to other people's words if if
they
only listen to words that say you gotta
be
more creative being more creative draw a
rainbow dog
with wings don't listen to things that
say
no there's no such thing as blue dogs so
stupid
eww say
well in the future what if their will
and if they say
no there's only brown dog no such thing
as blue
they'll get a bag they'll be blue dogs
if you'd like them to
get a dog and get um
coloring for dogs and color them blue
and see
my dog is blue then they'll be like
well yeah they won't have anything to
say
it's even as simple as the blue dog and
pink bunny
example for adults to remember
be imaginative be creative express
yourself that way
and help kids do that too and they'll
they'll be the ones that solve the
biggest challenges in the world
thanks again maya thank you everyone
thank you for watching
greatly appreciated love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below about
whoa
about how to not be a boring grown up
and your own imagination creativity
letting those
thrive and follow maya her
instagram link is in the bio below go
and check out some of her awesome videos
and
photos there and support the
young people the entrepreneurs artists
spiritual leaders
scientists engineers in the world that
you believe in support us be creative
be creative you can support us our links
are below that's right be creative
that's it guys that's it
thanks for tuning in don't forget to be
yourself see ya
i love it don't forget to be yourself
peace guys